the hardest part about writing is
getting your bum on a CD beginning
authors and put in too much action when
we Rick when we judge competitions one
of the things we find is that people
somehow seem to be putting cartoons on
paper it's what happened next and what
happened next and what happened next
what happened next it's really important
to stop you ask yourself what what is he
thinking now what is he feeling now
because Robert Browning said if you want
your songs to last base them on the
human heart and that is the root of why
people keep reading if it's just what
happened next like a cartoon you might
just as well go and watch a cartoon it's
probably done better
you quite often should go back to the
pinion just read it as if you were the
reader my agent is to BG Nepal injure
when she was my agent the last thing I
did when I finished a book and a book
might take over a year to write and take
it into a completely different room and
I would pretend to be her I would find
that I was holding a pencil and there
would be little skittles well I think
she's not gonna let me get away with
this and and then I would go back one
more time
and sort out the problems I knew she
would see reading it often with distance
yes it can improve a book enormously
it's very difficult to straddle the
commercial and the personal and and at
some level you may have to choose em if
you're lucky the sorts of book that you
truly truly truly want to write will
also turn out to be massively popular
and commercial and and everything but
it's not a given and you have to decide
for yourself which way you're going to
get readings absolutely vital to being a
good writer I mean every writer advises
this first I mean it's almost the first
device isn't it Robert Louis Stevenson
read read read read everything it's a
bit of a cop-out when you hear an author
saying oh I don't read when I'm writing
because I find it colors my style and
you think you can't have a very strong
style of reading something else this
book is going to color it and I've
created Larkin before but I will quote
him again he says when you write a book
you have to treat your own temperament
like a technical difficulty and you just
have to press on in spite of it because
and this is really important nothing you
write is ever as good as you hope or as
bad as you fear
you